joining me now to talk about all of this
and other topics killing it Kellyanne
Conway counselor to the president good
evening Killian I believe you heard a
little bit of that first of all these
specifics that the president she's
almost an interview saying that the
president knew about the WikiLeaks
emails before they came out and that
she's been interviewed by Special
Counsel Mahler your reaction to that
well that's the first I heard of either
this from Omarosa there's a lot that
she's saying that's new of course I mean
I will say that as recently as this
morning Imus referred to President Trump
as her mentor and obviously she's known
him almost the longest of any of us here
of going on 15 years he gave her many
chances on The Apprentice obviously in
the campaign here in the White House
it's a privilege to work in this
building for the country we all loved
every day and that's the way I'd say
most of us look at it the president has
made very clear the way he feels about
this book the way he feels about what he
sees as a betrayal he gave her many
opportunities and not only have I never
personally heard the president used a
racial slur against anyone in the
two-plus years I've been at his side
uninterrupted Brett
I never heard a Moroso complain about
the president doing that we know during
the campaign as you know at Fox News
there were rumors about a tape there
were rumors about a dossier nobody could
ever confirm the das verify the dossier
no one ever came through with the tape I
mean that's all we know and then we came
to work here on behalf of the people and
since we've gotten here he's been the
most successful president in modern
times no Sarah Sanders was asked that
question today and she says she's not
been in every room and she couldn't say
what
didn't hear and a lot of people jumped
on that about this tape lingering and if
there is a tape how do you get to the
bottom of this is the president gonna
have to dress this directly he has
addressed it he addressed it on Twitter
he rested to everyone I think that's
very important see this president on
social media it's important it's a
democratization of information everybody
hears the same thing at the same time so
let me ask why does he feel compelled to
keep tweeting about Omarosa doesn't that
give more attention to this book and her
charges the president feels like he
should be defending himself and also
reminding everyone that he has given her
many chances including all the way here
as assistant to the president in the in
the White House here's the tweet I don't
want to spend too much time on it but
it's obviously getting a lot of
attention when you give a crazed crying
lowlife a break and give her a job at
the White House I guess it just didn't
work out good work by general Kelly for
quickly firing that dog
first of all a crazed crying lowlife why
did he hire the president a new Amoroso
for many years and she had been very
active on the campaign I was looking at
clips just today where she is speaking
extemporaneously in mid to late October
2016
Brett with Donald Trump right behind her
waiting to introduce him at a rally in
Charlottesville North Carolina where I
was and she was emphatic about how great
he would be for all Americans including
african-americans in fact she worked
here for one full year and if I were
honor OSA I would try to take more
credit for being part of what ended up
being the lowest unemployment rate among
African Americans approach school choice
approach harder platform for this
president prison reform drug reform so
many different things new skills at
training and education higher education
things that will help everybody
including men and women of color years
ago two years ago people would tout this
pulled it Donald Trump at 1% among
African Americans nationwide that was a
phony poll but they didn't stop
everybody from touting and now he's at
29 percent among African
some polls they see the progress and
everything that this president has done
for all Americans I think is the news
that I frankly think the biggest news of
the day respectfully is is Peters trucks
firing and I want to talk about that in
a second but that last line quickly
firing that dog are you comfortable with
that language talking about a woman who
worked here in the White House I use
different language but I also know that
Don want people trying to get away with
saying that Donald Trump is terrible to
women who work for him and that he's a
sexist misogynist why would I be
standing here in front of the White
House working this building if I didn't
think this man was doing great for all
Americans and by the way if I felt that
he wasn't respectful toward women he's
an excellent boss to women it's only
some of the women out there on cable
news every single day who are jealous or
have no access or look at things through
their own Twitter feed and not through
reality who would think otherwise I have
always felt completely respected this is
a man I was in Republican politics for
decades he elevated me at almost 50
years old to be his campaign manager I
was hiding in plain sight for other
campaigns it's he who did that it's he
who won put me in charge of that
campaign me me counts for the president
made Omarosa assistant to the president
you mentioned the firing of Peter struck
and obviously has weighed in on all of
that many times most recently saying
they were all in on it clear Hillary
Clinton and frame Donald Trump four
things he didn't do quoting Greg jarred
on Fox and Friends if we had a real
Attorney General this which hook would
never have been started looking at the
wrong people
the real Attorney General Jeff Sessions
endorsed him first as you well know on
the campaign he hired him as Attorney
General so is he suggesting that his
Attorney General is not a real attorney
job the Attorney General is doing a
fabulous job on the matters for which he
has not refused himself like the ms-13
gangs the synthetic opioid surge so much
having to do with law enforcement
interdiction and the like it is the part
of this where he recused himself early
on I believe about March second or so of
2017 that's been frustrating to the
president but I think the real point of
that he's doing is that not realize
Attorney General well it is but he said
he's talking about the this whole
investigation he's talking about what
the president says
has been the fix has been in from the
beginning fixes me I think what's
important that Peter struck up fire
that's the firing that matters you've
got Peter struck Andrew McCain Jim call
me Bruce or is still at the department
justice on the taxpayer dollar why when
we know he was in cahoots with
Christopher Steele trying to dig up dirt
on Donald Trump why because they were so
desperate to prop up their presidential
candidate of choice Brett Hillary
Clinton they knew then she would be a
turkey of a candidate very weak very
pathetic on compelling not unsaleable to
the american public and they thought
they had to go get dirt on on donald
trump the president is merely saying
let's investigate both sides of this
equation you've got you now Peter struck
left you everybody saw him testifying in
front of Congress you look like a punk
with a smirk on his face and now he's
got a it's a big deal he raised $300,000
in a GoFundMe page maybe that's what
some people are doing with their Trump
tax cuts I think I want to ask you to
serve some questions the things that
that make a difference to a lot of
people one NAFTA is this coming to a
conclusion is this going to be wrapped
up especially with Mexico the team is
been working very hard I mean literally
day and night on the negotiations with
Mexico and the New Mexican president
alone I wasn't much great Mexico let me
start there they've been really working
on this deal with Mexico and hoping
maybe that could be a model for a deal
with Canada but you know this president
he prefers bilateral trade agreements or
multilateral he's made that very clear
but what he doesn't prefer is all the
times Americans American workers
American interests American ideals have
been screwed by these non-reciprocal
unfair imbalanced trade deals we have a
500 billion dollar trade deficit because
president's right left and center bread
have made terrible deals where I would
say non deals this president has
promised to balance that up so with
Mexico folks have been working on this
for a very long time really they feel
like they're in the final home stretches
they do they feel like they're in the
final homestretch they make that very
clear I won't get ahead of the President
and making the announcement but dealing
with Mexico separately and then perhaps
Canada were
last thing prison reform he said
Thursday one of the single most
important things we're doing is help
former inmates create in creating jobs
single most important are you thinking
that it's reality that you're gonna get
prison reform across the finish line the
president is very committed to making
sure that the people have paid their
debt to society and would be eligible
for these two but we also want to make
sure that they're eligible for one of
the six point six million jobs that have
been created the skills education the
employment opportunities were working
with secretary Acosta Department of
Labor we had this roundtable with Jared
Kushner and the president in Bedminster
on Thursday I participated with state
attorneys general and governors and they
are sharing their best practices this
president is also at the same time
making tremendous strides on the
nation's roiling drug crisis the crisis
next door it's open it's heroin
but it's also meth and and making sure
that we're treating the whole person a
whole-of-government approach Brett to
treat the whole person I think people
have been languishing for far too long
to pay their debt to society so this
president is very committed to helping
people and that's the latest example of
that tell him we appreciate your time
thank you friend the president out she
said his regards Iran right from the
Oval Office I almost thought he's going
to come with you he said tell Brett I
said hello hello until I have that shot
it